let's just remind viewers about what was
happened and what has happened there was
a a an investigation set up by the
government which reported back last year
into your brother's murder and it found
the metropolitan police to be
institutionally corrupt in part because
the metropolitan police was slow to hand
over documents and but this report today
has concluded that in fact the met
wasn't institutionally corrupt and any
hampering of the inquiry was not
deliberate but it was critical so the
inference here seems to be it's not
institutionally corrupt because they're
just not that organized
no i i would disagree with that because
if if the the the points raised in the
in the hmic press release the actual
points they raised about about their
the mets attitude to corruption an
extraordinarily lackadaisical
slapdash
uh attitude towards corruption it's
quite clear from that report i mean it
is a scathing report now whether you
call
uh
that ins that in itself institutional
corruption uh i would you know it is is
something that can be argued my view my
view hasn't changed one bit since the
uh since the panel report came out last
year and i'm sure that there is a
culture of cover-up and corruption in
the metropolitan police
and anybody anybody who has studied the
the way they work on this
um
i don't think they can come to
to any other conclusion so it's it it's
very interesting to see the report the
the hmic re report from today
uh
it is in itself a scathing report
as it says that the mets anti-corruption
the mets
uh system is not fit for purpose yeah it
says corruption is almost certainly
higher than the met understands it's not
fit for purpose it's fundamentally
flawed but it's not institutional we
spoke to matt parr the hm inspector
constabulary who authored this report
and he said that
he spoke about what he was saying there
indifference lacks vetting procedures
and blatant disregard it seems for
procedure and monitoring it sounds more
like incompetence
uh
i i would say it's a lack of work not
incompetence it's a lack of will they
have the skills he points out that in
the report they have skills in
anti-corruption but they
are not using them properly
yeah he he went on to say it's
unacceptable that 35 years after your
brother's murder the met hasn't done
enough to ensure its failings from that
investigation cannot be repeated in fact
we found no evidence that someone
somewhere had adopted the view that then
this must never happen again the met
have responded
and they've said that they realize
there's a lot to improve well in fact
work has already begun do you trust them
to improve
no
i don't frankly
i i mean i've i've my experience of
these people extends a for a long time
and
it took me
25 years to get them to admit
to
a tiny fraction of the corruption that
actually went on in that uh report that
the whole system the whole attitude that
i encountered was cover
cover-up cover-up
uh
alison do you think you'll ever get
answers also you and your family ever
get what you're looking for do you think
no no no no no we won't i mean
as far as i'm concerned this is really
as far as i'm going to go with this
obviously
um
i want to see improvement
i hope for it but unless there is root
and branch change in the in the
leadership of the police
and
uh the people in the home office and uh
people in who exercise political
oversight of the police unless there is
a unless that changes very markedly we
will see no improvement